Washington Journal continues Peter Lance
what is the government still covering up
about the 9/11 tragedy
well the biggest single finding that I
discovered when I was investigating the
9/11 Commission was that there's
probative evidence that al-qaeda was
connected to the crash of TWA 800 and
1996 this is the crash where 230 people
died on the way to Paris one night and
if that's true it would be the second
biggest act of terror and mass murder in
American history
the material the evidence was presented
by a forensic investigator to Governor
Kean in early April not a word of it
showed up in the 9/11 Commission report
what's the connection between the TW air
crash and the attacks on 9/11 well first
of all my first book a thousand years
for revenge I make the case that Romsey
Achmed Yusuf the Mozart of Terror was
the original World Trade Center bomber
and conceived the 9/11 plot in 1994 in
Manila with his uncle Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed everyone acknowledges Khalid
Sheikh is the is the quote mastermind
but Romsey was the true genius behind it
while Ramsey in addition to the 9/11
plot conceived a plot to blow up 12 US
jumbo jets heading in from Asia they
called it the Bojinka plot the plot was
foiled when it was a firing his bomb
factory he was captured with two of his
co-conspirators and in the spring of 96
he's awaiting trial for this Bojinka
plot in New York there's a mafia
informant on the same tear the federal
jail cell named Greg Scarpa jr. and
Yousef starts passing notes through a
hole in the wall I couldn't make this up
in a million years and these notes Rob
include intricate bomb schematics at
precise drawings chemical talking about
nitroglycerin RDX and used to have had
set a test bomb in a 747 in Manila in
1994 put it under the 26 row thinking
that would blow up the center of fuel
tank he was a few rows back wrong but it
killed a man in the seat blew a hole in
the floor now he knows it works they're
gonna push the bump forward like twenty
fifth twenty third row in the future and
blow up a dozen Jets that trial is about
to happen Yousef starts sending this guy
messages I'm worried about the trial
we're gonna have a bomb on a plane to
get a mistrial because there's a nun
sequestered jury and he figured if
there's a parallel event he could argue
well I'm in jail how could I have done
this so sure enough not only did the FBI
take him seriously but
people go to my website which is Peter
Lance comm my name click FBI 302 you can
read right now a dozens of FBI internal
Secret formerly secret memos which say
basically the document this the FBI took
it seriously he predicted he was going
to put a bomb in a plane and the day
after it happened Rob which happened on
the night of the most damaging evidence
going into trial he asked for a mistrial
then astonishingly the FBI when they put
a thousand agents out in Long Island to
investigate treated it like it was a
crime because they had been getting
these warnings they found high
explosives RDX PETN and nitroglycerin in
the area of the center-field tank
mirroring exactly the forensic evidence
from the bomb in the Philippines that
Yousef had set
so James Kallstrom the ADAC to the New
York offices assistant director in
charge was just about to call it a crime
I found in my investigation when he went
to a meeting in Washington DC with Louis
Freeh and Jamie Gorelick later to become
famous as one of the 9/11 commissioners
she was then Deputy Attorney General
whatever was said in that meeting
Kallstrom ran back to New York from
LaGuardia on the shuttle tried to kill a
New York Times story the next day that
was about to have evidence of the bomb
and literally when The Times refused and
ran the story the next day started
saying well maybe there are other
reasons explosives could be on a plane
absent a bomb they then began
investigating and they came up with this
insane theory if you ask me I mean even
hearing the theory when I first heard it
I thought this can't be true but they
accepted the theory that a k-9 officer
in st. Louis with a bomb sniffing dog
five weeks earlier had placed test AIDS
around the fatal flight as it was
waiting in st. Louis and that somehow
these aids had spilled that the officer
was negligent that somehow they'd
survived underwater for weeks and that
somehow they were then detectable by the
FBI and do you know Rob every single
media outlet the New York Times news day
everybody folded and next day everybody
just accepted this theory nobody sent
any reporter to st. Louis to interview
the officer even the FBI with a thousand
agents in New York didn't send anybody
to New York to interview the officer
they use local FBI and say Louis well I
got to that police officer to this
summer as I was putting my book together
he told me Peter I told them I thought I
did the test on a different plane there
were two 747s that day at the seat
concours in st. Louis
the fatal flight left at 12:35 fully
catered fully crewed 200 people for
Honolulu
he got off that flight at noon the plane
he did the test on was an empty plane by
its nature he left at noon there was
nobody on the plane 35 minutes later the
plane that became tea they were 800 left
but around the corner on the concourse
there was another plane that left at
1:45 it was in almost identical-looking
747 so add up the dots now let's connect
the dots and let's truly clearly this is
circumstantial evidence but let's
consider you've got a warning by the
Mozart of terror that he's going to put
a bomb in a plane he's giving a mafia
informant and this is documented by the
FBI the precise bomb formula including
the what they called later in court
Yousef signature the c106 resistor that
he wired into a Casio watch nobody
outside the Justice Department even knew
what that was until the summer this is
in May he's telling this mob guy with a
high-school education this stuff he's
saying you can use RDX instead of
nitroglycerin which was his original
chemical then on the eve of the most
damaged evidence going into trial is
that the plane takes off and by the way
everybody agrees the NTSB the FBI
everyone that the center fuel tank was
the engine of destruction of this plane
the question is why when the NTSB
finally pushed for the mechanical theory
and ultimately the FBI agreed they never
found a single piece of forensic
evidence to justify it no fur no wiring
no frayed wiring no float valve nothing
it's the single Bullet theory of the TWA
800 crash I believe what happened was al
Qaeda was had gone back in New York City
from 1989 I show in my first book that
they had established a beachhead in New
York the FBI had a kind of members under
surveillance as early as July of 89 they
did the first World Trade Center bombing
they then plotted the these three
incidents in Manila including the death
of the Pope
one of which later went on to become the
9/11 plot they were foiled but they they
executed the mirror' plot of Bojinka in
New York and July of 1996 the FBI the
FBI covering this up and we can get into
the reasons why what they did was they
put yourself away for 240 years
they also denigrated the Mafia
informants Scarpa who should have gotten
a
down release time he risked his life for
11 months they called his information a
hoax and a scam they put him in prison
for 40 years Rob for RICO violations now
no murder connected to him at all so I
believe what's happened is the Justice
Department made an n's means decision
and it was really a series of mafia
cases that would have come unraveled in
the Eastern District if they had
credited Scarpa they knew they had used
up for 240 years let's move on they
underestimated al-qaeda and now we're
paying the consequences one final aspect
of this is astonishing in in this
initiative that summer the FBI set up a
phone system where Yousef could call
outside the jail and they would forward
his calls to Asia to the Middle East and
we know at least once he called Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed the joint congressional
inquiry found that well here's his uncle
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed the mastermind of
9/11 who is the only Bojinka conspirator
who knows how to build the device is
still at large
could you staff have communicated to him
I need you to get that on a plane well
in fact he was speaking Urdu and
Bellucci and the FBI was listening with
a narrow Arabic translator and they
didn't know what he said and they may
have actually furthered this plot but at
one point used to have said that some
are thinking to Scarpa that he had mafia
guys well if you give me three thousand
dollars in my commissary account I will
introduce you to my people overseas the
FBI paid five hundred dollars initially
then refused to pay the other twenty
five hundred for twenty five hundred
dollars the Federal Bureau of
Investigation could have been connected
with Khalid Sheikh Mohammed in 1996 and
interdicted the 9/11 plot and it's all
in FBI 302 memos on my website Peter
Lance comm briefly explained what this
book cover up is about and why you wrote
it the book basically started out as an
analysis the 9/11 Commission because I
developed a source inside the Commission
who was telling me on a regular basis
their cherry-picking evidence and this
is on the left and the right this is you
know this is Democrats and Republicans
they're selectively focusing on the
evidence they're focusing from 1998
forward as opposed to going back to the
original World Trade Center bombing so I
looked at began looking at the
Commission and as I looked at the
Commission I actually testified on the
15th of March before the 9/11 Commission
governor Kaine read my first book a
thousand years for revenge over
Christmas but the very individual they
had take my testimony in closed-door
session and by the way when I went into
test
if I know stenographer no recording
device there's just a FBI agent who was
on the staff and Dietrich Theater
schnell the senior counsel he takes out
a notebook and he's writing notes I said
where's my where's my testimony on the
record well I'm gonna write this up and
don't worry it'll go on the record well
more than 90% of the witness intake for
the Commission was anecdotal Rob I mean
most people think when they see condi
rice put in her hand you know that
that's typical no more than 90% of their
intake was anecdotal further as it turns
out in an irony that I couldn't even
made up in my wildest dreams
Dietrich dieter schnell the very man who
took my testimony who was a team leader
for the Commission had been the
assistant prosecutor in the Bojinka case
and I have an FBI 302 showing he was a
party to this youssef intelligence this
man knew that the FBI had been warned
that a bomb was going to be placed on TV
over 800 now he's the senior
investigator for the Commission and not
a word of this showed up in their report
let's take a call from Warwick Rhode
Island good morning my questions looks a
little bit long but then I'll hang up
and all Rhode Islanders talk lungs I'm
violent too so go ahead okay based on
the administration we have and the tie
that has we had the Reagan Bush
administration okay and their support of
Saddam Hussein the Bush administration
also has ties to the thought okay we
have Vice President Dick Cheney
who in the Senate voted to decrease
funding for intelligence system both
both both Vice President Cheney and mr.
Rumsfeld violated rules that we had
about trading with Iraq when they were
in business they violated those those
bans we have heard this in pieces about
mr. Bush not paying and his
administration not paying attention to
the intelligence that was presented to
them prior to what happened in 9/11 and
we don't have a lot of transparency and
openness with this administration I
really would like to hear what mr. Vance
has to say
anything that he might have found out
regarding all this and how it
contributed thanks work okay I think the
Vice President was a congressman at the
time as opposed to a senator but in any
event I look as in I was very critical
of the Clinton administration in my
first book a thousand years of revenge
and in this book in fact this TWA 800
cover-up happened during Clinton's watch
but I would say that there are three
presidencies that bear some
responsibility George Herbert Walker
Bush because it was on his presidency
the FBI first had this evidence of an al
Qaeda cell in New York then of course
the Clinton eight years of Clinton but
also this presidency for there were 33
separate warnings and alerts in the
summer of 2001 George Tenet said the
light is blinking red Richard Clarke's
hair was on fire
the idea that they multiple foreign
governments from Russia to Israel to
Egypt were giving warnings to the United
States about a possible terrorist attack
and the fact that this administration
the fact that George Tenet had evidence
that Zacharias Moussaoui the only man
who's been indicted in the 9/11 plot had
actually you know tried to get
permission to learn how to fly a plane
but wasn't concerned about landing it
didn't even bring that up at the
principles meeting on September 4th is
extraordinary further the defense
failures of the day of with the greatest
defense failures in American history and
as I go my this book recounts minute by
minute using a great book called the
terror timeline by Paul Thompson which
has just came out as well which we take
minute by minute the events of that day
and it's just the president was in the
school secretary Rumsfeld was virtually
incommunicado he wasn't in the war room
at the Pentagon till after the building
was hit the Richard Myers the acting
chairman of the Joint Chiefs was behind
doors up on the hill with Max Cleland
there was an extraordinary series of
events that happen that day the people
are going to have to judge in November
as to who they think is better served
and it's an epic story blame can be
spread across three presidencies in any
case next up is ival Kentucky good
morning good morning thank you for
taking a call to me the cover-up
occurred under the Clinton
administration he had eight years I've
missed part of what the gentleman said
you
now but I know that Clinton could have
done an awful lot in his turn but he
didn't do it he got other things to do
may I add something else that's kind of
I have been kind on the undecided side
and this is one of the reasons I'm
concerned extremely concerned about
Curry's history of prostate cancer now I
don't know anything about Edwards I
don't know what kind of a president that
he would be and all I know about curry
is that when he speaks he slams or
smears foolish man we're gonna leave it
there we're gonna try and stay on the
topic of this book cover up what in your
in your writing in this book in your
opinion what responsibility does the
Clinton administration bear for the
attacks on 9/11
I think the Clinton administration bears
the responsibility in the sense that
they weren't they didn't pursue bin
Laden hard enough and I think that's one
of the things that came out very well in
the 9/11 Commission I'm not trashing
everything the 9/11 Commission had to
say they brought out some astonishing
findings I think that there was but if
they blame it on the reluctance of the
Defense Department under Clinton to take
the initiative you know there were the
you know attempts to take him out with
missiles but it could have been much
more pronounced and and you know they're
all worried all these according to I'm
being colloquial here but the generals
were worried about failing you know they
were just worried about what happens if
we continue to fail politically what it
would look like it could have done a lot
more but on the other hand this
administration had these seven months
leading up to 9/11 where this
astonishing warning signs were coming
through and this was the administration
that came into power on the promise that
they would have a strong military and
the military failures are just
incredible and I wanted a point can I
just say one other thing the relevance
of this book now and why TWA matters why
is TWA 800 matter today
well well well when condi rice said
there hadn't been any other threat to
America prior to the World Trade Center
on our soil if she if she knew and I
give her the benefit of the doubt that
she didn't know about this because I
believe that were a handful of people in
justice that did that knew about this
cover-up
it would have been much
significant perhaps this administration
would have had a greater warning perhaps
even President Clinton's administration
would have taken al-qaeda more seriously
two of the principles involved in this
Valerie Caproni who was the assistant
chief of the criminal division in the
Southern District of the Eastern
District of New York she is now general
counsel to the FBI she's the senior
lawyer in the FBI and Patrick Fitzgerald
who was head of terrorism and organized
crime in the Southern District he is now
the US attorney in Chicago and he's the
special prosecutor in the Joseph Wilson
leak probe investigation so you have two
people who these FBI memos on my website
Peter Lance comm two of the individuals
who were intimately involved in this
initiative on the on the intelligence
about TWA are now senior people in the
Justice Department under President Bush
I've called upon them on the talk shows
I've been on to come and answer some
questions also I think Dietrich Snell
should answer as to why this didn't end
up in the 9/11 report at least a
suggestion of it when wrote Louisiana
you're talking with Peter Lance good
morning good morning
well I had a couple other questions seem
like everybody else is asking but I do
have two I'd like to ask okay I haven't
heard any more about it but if you
remember back when we went into
Afghanistan hmm right off the bat bin
Laden was spotted and they had to call
back to Florida to get permission to
shoot him why hasn't that ever been
brought out also I would like to ask him
one question about these Taliban that we
had in Guantanamo Bay that we let loose
and they've gone back to Afghanistan and
we've killed at least two of those or
more and captured some is that a good
idea to let them go back to fight us
another day I'm gonna hang up and lift
something well I'd rather focus on I
don't know the specifics of either one
of those and I I would be I guess a
politician if I commented on something I
didn't know but I would like to say
something about the Taliban blind Sheikh
Omar abdel-rahman
people that remember the the famous
blind Sheikh was one of the keys to the
this entire attack on our country he was
the center of the original trade center
plot he was also a spiritual leader of a
plot to blow up the bridges and tunnels
around Manhattan convicted put in
federal prison two weeks before the Cole
bombing Osama bin Laden to give you an
idea of how intimate
Ramzi Yousef Khalid Shaikh the blind
Sheikh are all together two weeks before
the cold bombing when bin Laden had the
famous video fought while with the
dagger
he said free the blind Sheikh remember
al Sayyid Nosair kill rabbi cahana and
five days before 9/11 eight robbed they
offered to exchange the blind Sheikh for
the six Christian aid workers in Kabul
that the Taliban were holding so even
though the 9/11 Commission claims that
ramzi yousef and his group were part of
a loosely organized group of Sunni
Islamist I say that they were a tightly
organized group funded by bin Laden
going back to 1989 establishing a
beachhead in this country and if the
9/11 Commission missed that truth about
the origin of this plot what else did
they miss ARMA Massachusetts I'm sorry
Ayer Massachusetts go ahead yes good
morning
it's almost it's almost surreal that I'm
sitting here listening to mr. mr. Lantz
I just finished and I wonder if he if
he's aware of the book or if he's read
it jayna Davis's book on the 3rd
terrorist I am Oklahoma City bombing I'd
like to know your opinion of that book
and the facts because all of the players
in that book seem to be all the people
you've just this morning and you've just
kind of completely skipped that whole
episode and the that book seems
completely well documented I'm it's good
to read yours and see how it is done but
it seems very well documented with a lot
of big players
how about beau danske who did the
congressional hearing during that time
you probably wear that name yes and it
seems that you mentioned there were 31
warnings that we had for 9/11 from
reading the book it seems like we had
all kinds of warnings even pinpoint
warnings about a Federal Building in
Oklahoma just before the bombing I mean
days before we had warnings thanks for
your call yeah my if I can do a little
commercial here my first book robbed a
thousand years revenge I have an entire
chapter in that book on the relationship
between Terry Nichols and ramzi yousef
and the allegations that Ramsey used to
have taught Terry Nichols how to build a
bomb in Oklahoma City I I was the first
reporter ever to break that story in a
national forum and but I disagree with
Janie Davis she claims they're Iraqis I
say
not Iraqis in any event Jana and I are
both believed that there was an
middle-east connection to that bombing
and there's a whole chapter called John
Doe number two in my first book a
thousand years for revenge the reason I
didn't focus on in this book was that
that I also had mentioned the TWA 800
investigation in my first book but I
didn't have the evidence that I had and
you know all reporters are creatures of
the deadline and we were moving to press
and I wanted to focus on TWA 800 for
this book but I believe there's credible
evidence in Richard Clarke even said for
the first time in his book that he left
the door open that there might have been
a Middle East connection to the TWA to
the Oklahoma City bombing next up is
White Plains New York good morning good
morning I just like to say that I was
concerned that your your guests noted
Clinton's absence of doing something
about the terrorist organization when it
seems that he should have also mentioned
that the Congress was in the state of
total paralysis because all they were
interested in was impeaching the
President and there was no way that the
president at that time could do some
effective work in going after terrorists
if they if he did they would have
accused him of shirking and doing
something he shouldn't there was no way
Clinton could win I agree very much
Daniel Benjamin and this brilliant book
the age of sacred Terra points out how
Clinton's hands were tied
he had no ability even to interact or to
order Louis Freeh to do anything because
it would have been accused of
obstruction of justice there's little
doubt that the Lewinsky affair tied
Clinton's hands but I did but I doesn't
that doesn't excuse the fact that more
could have been done against bin Laden
during that period I mean you had the
African embassies in 1996 is when a guy
named Jamal alfadil walked into one of
the embassies turned himself in the CIA
had elf idol for six months then the FBI
they called him jr. he was the rosetta
stone of the entire al-qaida you know an
attack on America he went back to
Brooklyn mosque in 1989 he had actually
worked at the same mosque the FBI had
under surveillance he connected all the
dots for the bureau there was no wall
there was no stovepiping the FBI knew
exactly what was going on
all of this came out in u.s. versus bin
Laden On February 6 2001 months before
the 9/11 attack so one of the things
that's that's always troubled me is I
believe the Patriot Act was completely
unnecessary they and and now the house
has got legislation wanting to have even
more limited more of they want to
increase surveillance on American
citizens under kind of an expansion of
the Patriot Act if the if you go back
and you just look at a thousand years
revenge and I'm my website Peter Lance
comm click terrorism you'll see a
timeline that goes 32 page timeline you
can see how many times they blew it they
didn't need a patriot act they just
needed to do their jobs properly and I'm
not talking about the street or the
brick agents they're courageous people
like Nancy Floyd we're trying to do
their jobs and they were routinely
thwarted by management in the FBI this
is a management issue not an agent issue
was the 9/11 Commission report a
whitewash absolutely total whitewash it
was they gave the public what they
wanted to hear they gave the public some
sense that of urgency they shocked the
public in many cases and by revealing
some important evidence but the fact
that they left out even probative
evidence of a connection to TWA 800 and
more importantly the fact that Dietrich
schnell this individual who should have
been a witness in front of the
Commission was its lead investigator did
you know that he pushed the plot forward
the genesis of the plot from 1994 in the
Philippines when I had probative
evidence that it was started in the
Philippines between Khalid Sheikh and
Yousef he pushed it forward to 1996 and
he concluded among with his staff that
quote it made the evidence is out as to
whether or not Khalid Sheikh Mohammed
was a member of al-qaeda in 1996
absolutely absurd and whose word that he
take for that robbed the word of Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed which is like taking the
word of David Berkowitz for when the
first Son of Sam murder happened even
and they even quote in the 9/11 report
in a footnote saying that one of the
interrogators called Khalid sheiks
testimony truth accompanied by a
bodyguard of lies and yet the central
date of the 9/11 Commission for when the
plot of 9/11 began in 1996 was given to
them by its mastermind Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed that's a whitewash Dallas Texas
you're on with Peter Lance author of
cover up what the government is still
hiding about the war on terror
good morning this is my first time
calling c-span I want to bet you know
you're doing a wonderful job listen
Lance I appreciate the fact that you
have mentioned that knowledge about this
the things that have gone on I've gone
through several administrations I think
that's important for Americans to know I
had two questions one thing I want to
know what's the difference between the
Taliban and al-qaeda and number two I'd
like to know also most of the people
that they showed on TV that were
involved in the bombing in 9/11 were
from Saudi Arabia and I'm wondering why
what's going on with the United States
and Saudi Arabia it makes me feel this
because we have relationship with them
we somehow are not investigating Saudi
Arabia the way we should that most of
the people that were captured were from
Saudi Arabia not from Iraq I'm very
confused about that and I hope you will
give me some clarification on that issue
think two terrific questions
well the Taliban was the radical Islamic
government that was took power after the
Soviets left Afghanistan they were
essentially very friendly to bin Laden
they gave bin Laden safe harbor al Qaeda
or the base was this network this
tarrant network that bin Laden created
by taking over what was at the time
called the Mak it was a worldwide
network for collecting money for the
Mujahideen the rebels that we supported
by the way the u.s. gave three billion
dollars at least in aid which by the way
the Saudis matched dollar-for-dollar to
fight the Russians in Afghanistan only
when they left instead they turned their
attention on on us and we didn't seem to
pay attention to that I think your
question about the Saudis is dead-on
another thing that the 9/11 Commission
report did Rob as you know is that they
basically exonerated the Saudis for 9/11
they gave him a pass and that has caused
great concerns a Craig Unger's book
please get house of Busch House of Saud
it's one of the best books you'll ever
read I want you to buy cover up in the
thousand years for revenge but Craig
Unger's book is fantastic and he
documents the relationship of the Bush
family in particular with the Saudis
senator Graham's new book has
why we're 28 pages redacted from the
joint inquiry report of Congress and why
do they remain secret from the American
people clearly we need to know more
about the Saudi a potential relationship
now Ron motley of motley rice it's
ironic that the gentleman that was here
before me from the administration's
talking about how they have to limit
trial lawyers and have to stop trial
well the you know how the truth of 9/11
may eventually come out Rob trial
lawyers motley rice and Kreindler and
Kreindler another firm in New York are
suing the Saudi government over they
have over 5,000 clients to get to the
truth behind 9/11 who is representing
the Saudi government Baker James Baker
of Baker Botts who's a retainer of the
Bush family that's kind of a curious
thing but it may be that these trial
lawyers that many people malign might be
the ones that ultimately do what the
9/11 Commission failed to do Ron motley
is an extraordinary man he actually made
a lot of money in the tobacco
legislation where he fought for the
rights of you know people who were
injured in the tobacco companies he's
now fighting the fight to get to the
truth behind 9/11
Peter Lance has spent 15 years as a
print and network correspondent he was
last with ABC TV before becoming a story
editor and writer for the NBC series
crime story in Miami Vice he's also been
a co-executive producer of wiseguys on
CBS missing persons on ABC jag on NBC
and the Sentinel on UPN being involved
with these episodic television shows
does that at all call into question your
credibility as a journalist as because
you go back and forth between journalism
and fiction well I don't really go back
and forth anymore what my career has
been pretty much in three stages the
first stage was as a as a reporter I
started out of my hometown paper in
Rhode Island
Newport Daily News I won an award from
The Associated Press that was given the
year before to the Boston Globe for
Investigative Reporting when I was 18
years old expose on substandard housing
I won five Emmys
I went to Columbia j-school I have a
Juris Doctor degree from Fordham I made
a change in my career when I got married
and we had our child and went to
Hollywood and wrote fiction for about 12
years
but I returned to investigative
reporting after nine
eleven in earnest because I frankly
couldn't sit around and write fiction
while my country was under attack and
I've used all my skills and what I know
is a reporter to try and get to the
truth and I think this is the important
thing I'm just one individual and I
sight in both of my books the great
reporting that's been done before me by
other reporters the Washington Post and
New York Times etc but the truth of the
matter is if Peter Lantz an individual
reporter with just Google a phone card
tenacity and shoe leather could uncover
this kind of evidence why couldn't the
9/11 Commission uncover it and I think
that's the point
Oakland California on our other's line
good morning good morning I think taking
my call you're doing a wonderful job I
had a question if mr. Lantz has ever
heard of the tape painful deceptions and
the evidence about World Trade Center
building number seven thank you well
world trade seven is a very very
interesting question and I was gonna i
began really working heavily on it for
this book and again you have to pick and
choose maybe in the next book I'm going
to develop it more World Trade Center 7
is where New York City had its command
center also it's alleged that the Secret
Service had an office there and other
clandestine government agencies and it
went down it collapsed in the afternoon
it was the only building other than the
twin tower complex to go down that day
and the fire didn't even start according
to the officials until the afternoon
they ultimately blame the fire on a the
residual fuel tanks that were in the
building to power the generators but the
way from what my understanding is in my
investigation of the story those
generators were far removed from the
perimeter of the building that might
have been interdicted by any burning
debris it's a real interesting question
also if you look at the video there's
actually video the building down Larry
Silverman and other people who had with
the owner of the complex where it is
alleged that they use the word pull it
we better pull it and pull it as a is a
term in the in the building demolition
trade for bring the building down
intentionally so the question is whether
or not it was such damage that it was
damaged by the by the attack and that
there was such important information
in the building that they didn't want to
leave it porous and they decided to
bring it down whether it was brought
down as a result of the attack now this
is something I've never said before I'm
gonna say it here for the first time
there is evidence that an individual was
walking out of the garage and he was
arrested by the NYPD he was on a cell
phone speaking in Arabic he was wearing
a turnout coat and boots from from ten
engine and ten truck which is the fire
company just below the Trade Center he
was arrested by the NYPD a fire marshal
Andy de Fusco that I interviewed went
over to him and went to the processing
of the man's arrest he somehow was down
he was a messenger who was down in the
World Trade Center area prior to the
first plane hitting he as soon as the
first plane hit ten engine two-ton truck
the door went up he went in to install a
probationary firefighters coat and boots
and then he somehow found his way into
the inside seven World Trade Center
which is where the city's command center
was and as he was emerge any emerged
after both buildings had collapsed
pristine which clearly meant he was
inside that building during both
collapse he's talking on a phone cell
phone in Arabic he was arrested the NYPD
tried to turn him over to the FBI and
they said we're not interested and it is
an absolutely true story
his name was sue crude Dahl he claimed
to be of Turkish origin I went to the
messenger service that he worked in they
said he had no reason to be there that
day and he basically was given time
served and he's in the wind one of our
writer one of our callers our viewers
rather has written an email a
shoulder-fired missile has always been
blamed for the TWA 800 tragedy at the
time I don't think anybody wanted to
reveal that terrorists may actually be
living among us can you speak about the
possibility of the missile yeah I the
missile unfortunately is was the theory
that confused many people with respect
to TWA 800 many people many onlookers
saw what they believed to be a streak of
light that night and there was a whole
missile theory that in many journalists
including my former colleague Pierre
Salinger would discredited Rob over that
theory what happened was when the when
the bomb went off when the UCF's Acacio
nitrate device went off over the fuel
tank it created an event a flash and the
front of the plane was decapitated and
immediately plummeted to Long Island
Sound but the rest of the plane
continued rising for up to 5,000 feet
under its own power almost like a chick
with its head cut off I believe that's
what people saw they saw that they saw
the flash they saw the streak of light
and that's what got people confused the
forensic evidence is extraordinary that
the the identical bomb trigger powered
by a Casio watch with diluted
nitroglycerin or an alternative chemical
like RDX
placed over the center fuel tank is kind
of a blasting cap is what did the job
now William Tobin was the chief
metallurgist for the FBI and I asked him
when he said there was no indicia of
metallurgical damage consistent with a
bomb I said bill what which model did
you use and he said Pan Am 103 now Pan
Am 103 was a Toshiba boom box of sent
types of explosive that on its own
destroyed the plane this is a different
kind of model when I asked the retired
former chief metallurgist of the FBI if
he had used the Bojinka forensic
evidence of the bomb used to have set in
the Philippines he said what's Bojinka I
almost fell off the chair this man's
ruling was was very important to the FBI
ultimately of siding with the NTSB and
the mechanical theory
he never even tested there were only two
other bombs that had ever gone off on a
plane prior Pan Am 103 and P al 434 and
he never tested the USF's bomb in the
Philippines back to the phone's
Washington DC go ahead mr. Lanz I'm
reading cover-up right now the 9/11
Commission report has left out any
questions regarding five minutes after
the attack on the Pentagon here as I
walked down East Capitol Street behind
you out that window I was walking down
East Capitol Street
I saw a four-engine playing easing in
from the east I'd like to get that
information to you can I send it to her
Harper College I just send it send it to
my website it's Peter I don't have
electronic ops all right okay I'm so no
no okay send it to HarperCollins 10 East
53rd Street in New York New York thank
you love to connect with you thank you
thank you
Marietta Georgia you're on with Peter
Lance Marianna yes sir this is a
follow-up on the political restrictions
under the Clinton administration what
about the limitation of resources that
the FBI was under when they were
investigating all of the Clinton
scandals
did you find any evidence that doubt
those resources were taken away from the
you know these type of investigation
well I didn't find that but I'll tell
you what I did find and and this has
been documented by other journalists
like John Miller the the fact of the
matter is ironically there were a
thousand agents assigned to the TWA 800
investigation now John O'Neill who is
beloved who as you know was considered
the man in the FBI who was the one that
recognized that bin Laden threat better
than anyone who ironically left to
become head of security at the World
Trade Center and who died that day
himself ironically John O'Neill John
O'Neill ultimately according to John
Miller put pressure on James Kallstrom
the New York ADAC to close down the TWA
an 800 investigation because he felt it
was drawing resources away from the
investigation of the war on terror I
mean that to me is the ultimate irony
even a man as astute as John O'Neill
didn't understand that there had been
this cover-up and that to me is
extraordinary that all these thousand
agents who were really working on
something related to the war on terror
well ultimately dispersed back into
other positions with respect to Clint
and I just don't have the numbers on
that one of the things that you talk
about in the book is the fact that there
were actually war games or testing runs
going on in the Washington DC area
during the day of the attacks explain
that well there are three separate war
games on 9/11 one was called vigilant
Guardian which took place in the
Northeast air defense sector of NORAD
which covered from New England down in
Washington it was run out of Rome New
York and Lieutenant Colonel dawn desk
ins who ran the exercise was actually
quoted later as saying she was confused
when the first planes began reports of
the hijacking there was another one
called North northern vigilance Rob over
like the northwestern part of the US
with Canada but one of the most ironic
ones was conducted by the National
Reconnaissance Center and this is the as
the agency that runs the network of spy
satellites they have a facility near
Dulles where one of the hijacked planes
took off from and their exercise was
envisioning what would happen if a plane
hit one of their buildings and so those
three exercises now virtually none of
that is in the 9/11 report and
there were the day of the hearing on the
17th of June when John farmer presented
the day of report there was there was
virtually no mention I think it was a
question by Tim Romer at the very end of
the hearings I think that again it's
here's one other thing there were two
planes f-16s from the hundred and
seventy-seventh Fighter Wing of the New
Jersey National Guard
there are now two different reports one
report was that they're actually
airborne over the Pinelands of southern
New Jersey and a more recent report
we've just gotten paul thompson and i
was that they're on the tarmac ready to
take off from atlantic city Pomona
Airport ready to rock you know that
morning and that they were held back on
the tarmac and and and and basically
were ineffective later dispatched
towards Pennsylvania which is kind of
ironic in any event those planes were
eight minutes from lower Manhattan and
the 9/11 report says and that they were
FAA tried to contact a defunct NORAD
base in Atlantic City and got no
response well in fact it wasn't defunct
it was an it may have been defunct for
NORAD but it was an active Air National
Guard base with planes that could have
at least our interdicted the second
plane even if they had defensively flown
toward the plane and diverted it from
the tower they could have minimized the
loss of life and they were never even
contacted and that is not in the 9/11
report Norwich New York good morning
Norwich I just wondered do you feel that
had President Bush returned to
Washington after that August 6th
briefing which was pretty even definite
briefing and directed the FBI and the
CIA did and everybody else to get to the
bottom of these threats we might have
averted 9/11 absolutely well I don't
know that it could have been averted it
was well into motion but I think the
fact that the president was on vacation
that he got a got a daily briefing
August 6th and said bin Laden determined
to attack the u.s. that they were
consistent 31 to 33 warnings throughout
the summer and that there was all this
evidence if you then begin to straight
the President of the United States the
commander in chief had pulled together
all the resources of counterterrorism at
that moment including Richard Clarke
brought George Tenet into a room brought
the FBI acting director Tom Picard into
the room then they may have learned
about the Phoenix memo about flight
schools they may have connected that to
Zacharias Moussaoui I mean this is not
that difficult to think if you
when you look at what was in front of
them but it needed to be coordinated and
the coordinator at the time was on
vacation in Texas there's no other way
to say it it's the truth and to me
though in his absence George Tenet the
CIA director to have gone to a
principals meeting in September with
knowledge of Messiah and not even bring
it up as incredible now he's gone tenet
is really I guess the only and his
deputy director of operations are the
only casualties people should be asking
the following why did the 911 Commission
not have any accountability why did they
not blame anybody they keep talking
about institutions well people aren't
make up institutions robbed and how can
you say year after year mistake after
mistake after mistake after mistake
nobody gets fired that's like saying
well we'll keep Enron's management in
place but we're just going to reposition
them you know I mean that the widows at
christen bright wiser Laurie van Ark and
Mindy Kleinberg Patty Kasasa the Jersey
Girls Monica Gabriele Beverly akhirat
the women who got through their own
heart and soul got this commission into
being that was their main goal
accountability let's find out why our
husbands died let's find out who made
the mistakes and none of it there's no
accountability in the 9/11 report they
said we don't want to be in the blame
game well the American public will have
to judge Peter Lynch thank you for being
on the program
thanks so much Rob really great thank
you we want to go now to well actually
first we want to tell you that in just a
few minutes we're going to open up the
phones we're gonna have open phones for
about 15 minutes and then we'll be
talking with Ann Lewis from the
Democratic National Committee about the
2004 vote and the numbers there for open
phones are on the screen
202 seven 37000 to supporting President
Bush six to eight zero to 0-5 supporting
Senator Kerry and six to eight zero one
eight for supporting all others